bene a tutti i ragazzoni lo è stato oggi
ho finito di mangiarmi sul perché mi
sono io mi ordinò il sushi o un certo
livello di tristezza come persona
comunque ragazzi questa settimana sono
successe due miliardi di cose e ho
pensato di fare un mega mix di tutte le
cose che sono successe così alla cazzo
di cane spero vi piaccia
[Musica]
ma cos'è natura e va bene tecnico mita 2
milioni di views poi vedere tutto il
movimento a sant angelo bonelli la prova
di un tia decido io inquieta ma io ti
ammazzo
non ti sparo più vasta
[Musica]
canta ancora staff magna come stai
siamo in cascina ecco i turisti che
arrivano a vederci anno arrivando qua
per vedere noi non per vedere gli
animali e per vedere noi che siamo delle
persone più brutte degli animali grazie
di essere venuti adesso vi daremo lo
spettacolo giorgio gaga per terra bravo
giorgio niente sono esattamente come un
animale non riesco a scavalcare se ci
sali saliva attimo ho pensato ecco poi
vai vai sull isola di wight si è fermato
guarda ha notato che c'è stato un
intoppo c'è giuseppe che praticamente
allo stivale incastrato pieno di merda
che cos'è la thema tieni si spacca
l'assegno e poi pieno di merda neanche
nel vedere che la giusta chiuse chiuse
dai maya il porco di merda che è uscito
bellissimo creare scarpe pd e il terzo
ancora come cammina più di scalzi
spavaldo
[Musica]
ma dai
tanto io cane siamo in questo parco tipo
favela c'è una roba assurda
però c'è wifi come cazzo è possibile ad
essi mi che si danno la mano secondo
scimmie che si danno la mano delle cose
sarà come contento sasha
ma in tutto questo perché claus in
mutande ciabatte e mutano no regalare
galles per farmi vedere questo usando un
caso è ridotto e stato ce l'hai fatto a
toglierlo come una macchina macchina
mazza da golf occhiali una chitarra
sgonfia bellissimo fogli benji prima
voglio detto pippo no no devi andare
avanti da fermo a ok va bene allora
aspetta ecco fotografo bordo campo
ronaldinho da quasi s roberto carlos se
fai gol
la deve ritirare i veri davanti quindi
il gol non l'ho visto io sono il tiro e
perché ieri davanti è la rete tirato
dritto per dritto ai dopo veri 0 a
[ __ ]
nella video quello del 3 era del canale
mercato attraversa lira bona quindi
adesso segneremo di rabona ciman colpo è
arrivato al pubblico che più raro
prendere il palo di far gol e
complimenti mangiare il sushi tra
l'altro mi sono anche sporcato di schifo
di salsa di soia perché ovviamente
nell'aprire la vabbè tanto mi conoscete
però che vi sia piaciuto
facciamo che vado a lavare la maglietta
e vado a dormire perché anche un po
tardi si in questo momento sto
registrando che tipo l'una di notte ho
finito di montare il video ci sono un
sacco di progetti che sto facendo che
sto portando a termine però non posso
parlarvi di nulla perché sono tutte
quante sorprese quindi mettiamola così
se però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
che mi è piaciuta un commento è un e
piace anche la pace di facebook e comuni
tiziana epic news ho ritrovato il pezzo
dietro del telecomando prima per tenere
le pile avevo lo scotch che adesso ho
tolto quindi siamo ritornati al
telecomando originale in quattro anni
ancora non si è rotto credo che questa
merda sia più resistente di un nokia di
quelli vecchi
scegliamo un prossimo video ragazzi